I'd like to call to order this
continuing education event for the
children and family law committee and
the Judiciary Committee
we found that some of the bills that
have come before us having to do with
the law or the Judiciary Committee we're
not ready for prime time
sometimes there were misuses of legal
terms sometimes the rules of Criminal
Court were soon to be the same as the
rules for civil court and so on and I
got to thinking if we had a continuing
education event and brought senior
senior Judiciary people to us they could
make a presentation to us and we would
learn some more things about the law so
next time our bills would have a greater
chance of being heard and not either
killed or retained here's the format for
how we're going to be working today
the
Judiciary folks will introduce
themselves and make a presentation
if along the way you have a question
you will go over to the table where the
committee researcher is
waving
cards at you and her hand too and you
will fill out the question on the card
we will not take questions from the
audience in a direct verbal way you'll
fill the cards out and there's a box
where you'll put them in
somewhere along the line
Judiciary Committee chairman Bob Lynn
will pick up a pile of those cards and
sort them by type because many of the
questions will be similar to other
questions so we'll group them or he'll
group them so that we can ask one
composite question
it's not proper to raise a question
about a particular court case
first of all because that is considered
unethical in a case like we're in today
secondly the justices may not be
familiar with it and thirdly we're not
looking at particular cases we're
looking at process what is the process
is it being followed should there be a
different process what is the procedure
those are the kinds of broad questions
that can be put to the justices
now in a meeting with chairman Lynn and
the justices I came to the belief that
they are coming both to explain but also
to listen
and there will be some things where I
know I'll learn a lot I made assumptions
that were incorrect
but they're also going to hear some of
the many concerns that people have
raised and until he proved to me
otherwise I think they're going to do
something about it and as I told them
those are the nice carrots the stick I
have in my back pocket is several
retained bills that are really
trying to straighten out Judiciary so
I've got that stick I don't think I'll
need it
but I got it so now that I've pretty
well alienated everybody in the room
I will call upon the Chief Justice sir
if you would introduce yourself and your
colleagues
good morning Mr chairman Mr chairman and
members of both committees thank you
very much for the opportunity to be here
with me today is the administrator of
the Circuit Court David King Judge David
King and to my right is Judge Michael
Garner who is a Circuit Judge sitting in
Laconia New Hampshire and it previously
served as a mayoral master
if I just can dive in Mr chairman please
do sir um and you're quite correct we we
had the honor of meeting with both of
the chairs and um we we wanted this
opportunity to come and brief you on
some Basics about the Judiciary also
give you a briefing on what something
called the weighted caseload study which
is a evidence-based analysis of the
resources that our Judiciary needs in
New Hampshire
and then judge king is prepared to give
the Committees some statistics relating
to the Family Division and judge Gardner
who uh is very well versed in this area
of the law and the procedure is prepared
to help the committee and members of the
public with questions relating to that
so we are very grateful for the
opportunity I do want to reiterate what
the chair said we want to hear comments
we want to hear feedback as public
officials that's our duty and if we can
do better we want to do better and it is
in that spirit that we are here
I do have slides and I've distributed I
think every member of the committees has
them uh so I've covered slide two uh
Chief would it be possible if we have
some left over we keep a few for
committee members who aren't here but
those particularly in the audience who
are house members and Bill writers might
have access and
maybe the way they're distributed people
could look on with one another
thank you sir okay slide number three is
our mission
and it is something that we take very
very seriously and we try to live by
every day and that goes through before
not just the judges but our 800
employees in the judicial branch
the next slide just gives you a visual
overview of the judicial branch we are
comprised of two trial courts the
circuit court and the Superior Court one
Appellate Court the Supreme Court and
one office that provides administrative
support for the Judiciary it's called
the administrative office of the courts
and I'm going to detail or judge king
and I will detail each one of these
courts just to level set everyone and I
recognize in advance that for many of
you this is uh you're well versed in
this but I want to just make sure we're
we're all on the same page
uh circuit court judge king
thank you Chief so I'm on slide six and
uh by way a review for some of you and
maybe new for others the Circuit Court
was created uh with an effective date of
July 1st 2011 by this body it's a
legislatively created court and at the
time we were under some fairly we the
state of New Hampshire were in some
fairly tight budget times and we were
asked to get creative and see if there
are ways that we could create
efficiencies for the state in the court
system and what we did at the time was
we took three limited jurisdiction
courts we took the district court the
Probate Court where I came from and the
Family Division and we collapsed them
into one court and we called it the
Circuit Court we just kind of pulled
that name out of the air I said we
called it the circuit court because
Supreme Court was already taken so we
needed to come up with something so we
called it the circuit court and the bill
was introduced in January of 2011 and I
think Governor Lynch signed it in
mid-may it was one of the biggest
changes in the court system since the
consolidation in 1983 which was House
Bill 200 back then I was a member of
House Judiciary in the 8384 session
which I was shocked to do the math today
was 40 years ago but we when we created
the Circuit Court it was House Bill 609
and we had asked the legislature for 10
years to implement it so that we could
do the restructuring by attrition and we
were told that we had to implement it by
July 1st so we did we went from 115
clerks and deputies across those three
courts down to 52
clerks and deputies we brought all those
folks into a room and we said we're
going to post 52 jobs you're all free to
apply but basically half of you are
going to lose your jobs and it was
probably one of the most difficult
things I've done in court administration
and so and at the time we had 45
full-time judicial officers on the bench
across those three courts Inc which
included 13 marital Masters and today
there's only one of those left and it's
me the rest are the other 44 judges and
Masters have retired summer some Masters
are now judges like judge Garner some
part-time judges have become full-time
judges but of those 45 judicial officers
44 are no longer on the bench
slide seven uh it was no mystery to the
creation of this we created 10 circuits
and each County was a circuit and we
wanted to try to change as little as
possible uh to try to get this through
the legislature as seamlessly as we
could so we have 34 Circuit Court
locations around the state they're all
depicted on this map we have 10 probate
divisions those were the where the
probate courts were originally
established in the county seats and now
we have a district Division and a Family
Division and all of the other 31
locations since we created the Circuit
Court we've closed plastow which was a
really small Court down in the lower
part of the part of the state
slide eight gives you what we're using
as a an annual circuit court case volume
and because of the covid-19 pandemic and
a pretty significant reduction in many
different case types we have used the
average of fiscal years 17 18 and 19 but
using those years of the circuit court
case volume is over 126 000 cases a year
in addition to that we have a number of
cases that are reopened and just in the
divorce parenting world that's another 3
700 to 5400 cases a year that get added
to our dockets
on the next slide uh what we show the
number of Circuit Court judges and the
chief will explain the weighted caseload
study but currently as of today we have
41 full-time judges on the bench we have
one full-time vacancy and we actually
have five part-time judges because judge
Maloney just turned 70 and she's now a
referee in addition to that we have
four senior active judges that we use
from time to time who can work part-time
those are Judges who have retired but
are still under the age of 70. we have
one marital master who is retired who
still
sits occasionally and we have 12
retired judges who are over the age of
70 that we still need in order to try to
meet the caseload that we have because
we just don't have enough judges so 12
judges over age 70 who are regularly
hearing cases as senior referees and
everything that that they do has to be
co-signed by a judge so it's not a real
efficient use but we schedule in the
Circuit Court by judge days
so if you take those 126 000 cases using
the weighted caseload that translates to
16 352 judge days that we need to move
the volume of cases that we have
for this year calendar year 2023 when we
put the judicial schedule together
we were able to Cobble together ten
thousand five hundred and eighteen days
so that's all of the full-time judges
that's the part-time judges we have five
part-time judges they sit anywhere from
a handful of days up to a couple hundred
days they tell us how many they are
willing to do when we try to add a few
more to that
and then we take the senior active
judges and the referees War over 70 and
that all of those all in added up to ten
thousand five hundred and eighteen days
so you can see where where thousands of
days short of scheduling what we need to
be able to move those cases
our other trial court is the superior
court if you go to page 11 is a brief
description of the jurisdiction of the
Superior Court it is our court of
General jurisdiction it is the only
Court in our state which has conducts
jury trials
uh it it has uh jurisdiction over all
felony crimes and all civil matters over
twenty five thousand dollars so a very
wide
uh range of jurisdiction on the next
slide you will see what
I'm sure is very familiar we have 11
Superior Court locations in New
Hampshire
one in each County two in Hillsboro in
Manchester in Nashua
on slide 13 you will see the analog to
what you saw in slide 8 with the Circuit
Court
about 18 000 cases in superior court
over the same period of time that judge
king described and you can see the
breakdown in the um in the in the
graphic the largest cohort of cases are
criminal cases
the next slide you will see our head
count in Superior Court it has remained
unchanged uh since at least 2011 we have
21 authorized judges and one chief
justice currently we were fully
accounted for in terms of judges no
vacancies at the moment
so those are our true trial courts we
have one Appellate Court in New
Hampshire that is the Supreme Court
Supreme Court sits here in Concord and
on page 16.
you will see the justices of the Supreme
Court there are four associate justices
and one chief justice
in addition to our duties and as
appellate judges we serve as leaders of
the judicial branch and the Chief
Justice in particular has administrative
responsibilities for the judicial branch
our duties include
overseeing issues such as attorney
discipline attorney emissions liaison
with the New Hampshire Bar Association
and development of court rules
on the next slide slide 17 you will see
our breakdown of cases it's about
625 650 cases a year of that about
150 125 to 150
receive full-blown oral arguments and
and decisions that are reported in the
New Hampshire reports I just came from a
day of oral argument to be over here we
hold them about four times four to six
times a month
the rest of our cases are all
handled there are five sets of eyes on
every single case that runs through our
court they're just disposed of in
various different ways including by
orders and so on
the next slide we are supported by the
administrative office of the courts
about 55 people who work there their
location is over at one Granite place
and they they provide support in terms
of Information Technology Human
Resources legal government relations
that are back office support
and it's a fairly complex organization
as you've seen in our slides we have
over 40 locations around New Hampshire
and about 800 employees
so let's begin the discussion of
what what is called the way to caseload
study and if you turn to page or slide
um
of two legislatures ago judge king can
correct me uh this legislature
authorized uh appropriated funds for us
to undertake a way to caseload study a
weighted caseload study is an
evidence-based analysis of how many
resources we need in terms of judges and
case processing staff given our case
load
in a way to caseload study is in
contrast to other ways that that policy
makers may decide how to assign judicial
resources
but we feel this is the best most
reliable
evidence-based
means to do it and our feeling is backed
up by legislation which was enacted in
which by which this legislature endorsed
a way to caseload study one was
conducted in 2005 and then
one was conducted last year in 2022.
um slide 21 talks about other methods
that may be employed to determine how
many judges and Court staff we need
population-based formulas for formal is
based purely on the number of cases but
again
um in 490f Colon 11 this legislature has
endorsed a weighted caseload study
on slide 22 I
the basic methodology the basic approach
is to take the number of cases determine
a case weight and then determine how
many resources measured in core
personnel and judges are needed to make
our workload
on slide 23
this is the history of our weighted
caseload study in New Hampshire as I
mentioned one was conducted in 2005 at
the time the trial courts had 482
positions
in 2022 when we conducted this study
there were 514 positions
do this study we on next slide
slide 24 we retained the services of the
national Center for state courts the
national Center for state courts is an
extraordinary resource which serves all
State and territorial courts in our
country
and they have substantial experience and
expertise since in assisting
jurisdictions in doing way to caseload
studies both for judges and staff so we
retained them to assist us with the
study
on the next slide slide 25
you will see a basic methodology or
calculation for how a weighted caseload
is determined for one of our case types
small claims are heard in the Circuit
Court
and you can see that if you look at the
the chart on the right hand side of
slide 25
during our survey period which was six
weeks at the beginning of last year
judges uh
recorded in court processing staff
recorded 22 324 minutes
to um
that they worked on small claims
cases there were 29 days of collection
during this period you divide those two
numbers and then multiply it by the
number of judicial working days
and you have the Statewide annualized
minutes for small claims cases
then you divide that
by the number of court filings for small
claims and you see that the case weight
for this case type is 12.38 minutes
which means on average a judge spends
12.38 minutes on a small claims case
now is my colleagues will explain that's
an average I mean it's some or less some
are more small claims cases can if
they're if they're settled no no time is
needed or recorded but that's the
average and it this this slide is simply
to demonstrate how we come up with a
weighted case
number
uh
is a
we needed data for each one of our case
types and our staff and judges recorded
the data as I said for 29 days at the
beginning of last year
and it was those that time that was the
essential data point that helped us
build our conclusions
and led to our conclusions on page slide
27 you will see our Baseline staff for
the weighted caseload study at the time
it was conducted
broken down by judicial officers in
various categories of staff
on the circuit court side you will see
that there are 44.32
judicial officers included in the study
at the time I just want you to footnote
that because we'll come back to it and
explain
explain that
number a little bit more in the context
of our conclusions
on the next slide you will see that we
had extraordinary participation and
therefore highly reliable data we had a
hundred percent participation by our
judges and our staff
over 29 days so in addition to doing
performing their day-to-day function
functions and serving the people of our
state in our court system they were
recording the time on each one of the
case types they were working on
on slide 29 we summarize the results
um
the national Center found that we needed
563.77 judicial officers and staff to
process cases
in both of our trial courts and that's
about 50 more positions than in our
current budget
and of those broken down the Circuit
Court needs were identified as an
additional 37 positions in Superior
Court an additional 12 positions both
judges and staff
I want to uh if we could just go out of
order skip to slide 31.
in addition the study
tried to capture a very important data
source which is the reality in both of
our trial courts is that clerks Deputy
clerks and other managers are actually
doing the work of our court Assistance
or core process our case processing
staff
and you can see that across both trial
courts that
work that's impounded in our clerks and
our Deputy clerks that should be with
court processing staff amounts to
57.3 positions in both of our trial
courts broken down by about 40 in the
Circuit Court in 17 and a half in the
Superior Court
so in addition to the numbers that we
saw on page 29 these are also the
reality of what we're dealing with we
have clerks and Deputy clerks who are
who are doing case processing work and
that's a key data point that we're able
to capture
oh on page 30
um
this summarizes
the basic conclusions of the national
centers work for us which
um in the Circuit Court in terms of
judges
um
we
require
21.35 additional judges
but I want you to footnote that we'll
come back to it and you can see the
breakdown among staff in Superior Court
three and a half new judges
and for the most part additional staff
is needed
it's broken down on page 30.
so page 32 I'm going to ask judge king
to explain this
page 32 level sets the
the number of judges
that the national Center identified with
the reality of judicial resources
available to us because the national
Center did not capture the work of some
of our per diem or of our per diem
judges and this chart explains
explains that
so this page actually shows what we had
available to us at the during that six
week period of data collection on the
ground in the circuit court so we had at
that time 40 full-time judges we still
had one marital Master we had a
full-time child support referee which
was counted as a judge a part-time child
support referee
and then we have we had two we now have
one holdover salaried district court
judges so these were judges that were
appointed before the Circuit Court was
created were appointed to a specific
court for example the Portsmouth
District Court they are still considered
a salary judge and they received the
salary by Statute for that Court to
which they were appointed until they
retire or they turned 70. that's just
unless they become a full-time judge so
it's a little bit of a one-off for us we
have to take the weighted caseload for
that court and then do the math and
that's how their salaries are calculated
um
and then there were adjustments made to
that for
um
there were two authorized full-time
judges in addition to that one marital
Master had retired and one of the two
salary judges had retired and we added a
full-time probate referee just about
exactly when we were doing the study
which was authorized by the legislature
to be able to process our electronically
filed Estates thereby kind of freeing up
a judge from doing that work
and if you get to the bottom line that
the total total shortfall is 17.32
so one on slide 30 the national Center
had identified
21.35 additional judges once you true it
up the real number as as judge king just
explained that the number is
17.32 additional judges needed that is
the bottom line of the study in the
Circuit Court three and a half judges in
the Superior Court
now I'm going to ask both of my
colleagues if they want to explain what
the consequences of not having adequate
an adequate number of judges in court
processing staff are in terms of the
reality of their the caseload in circuit
court and basically how cases are
triaged
yeah so I'll take a stab at that Chief
um as I said earlier in my comments the
weighted caseload
calls for 16 352
judge days for 2023 to move the number
of cases and we we can break that down
by case type but there are a lot of
cases that this legislature has told us
have to be resolved in certain time
frames so our landlord tenant cases our
abuse neglect cases our juvenile
delinquency cases some guardianship
cases civil protection orders uh chins
termination of parental rights that's a
big chunk of what we do and even during
the covid-19 pandemic we were required
by Statute to get those cases resolved
in the time frames that you set for us
and we were able to do that we didn't
miss a deadline we had some exceptions
for landlord tenant by Court rule
um but there are a number of cases that
there just are not enough judges on the
bench to get to and those are the cases
that you're hearing from your
constituents that aren't moving as
quickly as they should and we do not
dispute that they are absolutely right
um there are criminal cases that involve
non-incarcerated defendants that it's
taking longer than we would like to get
scheduled for trial and certainly in the
divorce parenting Arena we're not
getting to those cases nearly as quickly
as we would like those are the kinds of
cases that don't have statutorily
dictated deadlines and so we triage the
cases that we have to reach and there's
got to be some slippage somewhere and
it's primarily in non-incarcerated
defendants small claims in civil cases
and in the divorce parenting cases in
order to meet our deadlines we would
need the judges that the weighted
caseload study says that we need so I
think I'm really proud that our judges
are doing as as well as they are doing
they work nights and weekends to try to
stay on top of things but there is
definitely a gap and we are not reaching
the time to disposition in all of our
cases in the fashion that we would like
to or
being perfectly upfront about that I've
talked to both chairman about that and
it's not a mystery
judge Garner can probably talk about how
we triage
so I was here a couple of months ago I
think to be introduced to the children
and family law section it's nice of you
to have me back again I'm glad to be
back again
just by way of introduction I'm a
circuit court judge I've been a judge
for about seven years I sit in Laconia
almost all of the time
and I'm as a circuit court judge trained
to do all three of the divisions probate
district and family
as it happens we have more work in the
Family Division than in District and so
my week typically is two or three days
of Family Division maybe one or two days
of District division the occasional
probate division assignment my family
days are typically either a full day
contested one hearing case that's been
pending for a while or a list day which
is typically 30-minute hearings back to
back beginning at 8 30 and ending at
four o'clock with the lunch hour if I
can conjure that up somewhere
let me just add to what judge king was
saying in terms of our triaging on the
micro level
we have a divorce and parenting cases
which have an enormous spectrum of
complexity some of those cases are
resolved virtually at the time that
they're filed and it's simply a question
of reviewing the paperwork making sure
the forms are in order and approving it
sending it out
some of those are cases which begin in
difficult ways and go through a series
of hearings that may be prompted by
emergency motions or other features
unique to the case
May ultimately end up with full day or
sometimes multi-day final hearings that
involve multiple Witnesses
there may be a guardian that Litem
involved there may be contested
parenting issues contested Financial
issues alimony support property
distribution all of that may be
supported by exhibits which in my recent
experience tend to be expanding rather
than Contracting
and so those cases those complex divorce
and parenting cases are a little bit
unpredictable we don't know which cases
are going to turn into that when they're
first filed we don't have much control
over that
our triage process though on the micro
level on a daily basis is really
threefold
we have emergency motions that are filed
every day again unpredictably either in
divorce parenting cases when there's an
emergency that prompts one party to come
to court and ask for immediate orders or
in domestic violence petition sorts of
cases
in Laconia we get 350 more or less
domestic violence petitions every year
it's unpredictable for us when those
cases are going to come in although we
inexperienced know that Friday afternoon
and Monday mornings tend to be the times
but every day we're going to get
emergency motions that are filed those
motions are reviewed by a judge every
day
not a single one of those cases comes in
and lacks review by a judge and a
decision by a judge whether to Grant an
emergency protective order or emergency
relief and from time to time because our
protocols allow and require for a
hearing for the party who has been
denied relief when they first come in
occasionally those motions and those
filings result in the need for having a
hearing that day
that's pretty rare but it happens
regularly enough that it's worth
mentioning so that's the overlay to our
daily work otherwise our daily work is
managing the cases that have to be
scheduled according to the statutory
deadlines that judge king mentioned
those cases have to be scheduled they
have to be heard and the orders have to
be entered within the certain statutory
deadlines and behind those come our
cases without statutory deadlines and of
varying levels of complexity so my day
is going to be either one or the other
typically in Family Division it's either
a list a or a full day or more than one
full day of final hearings and in the
middle I'm going to get a Sprinkle of
emergency motions that are filed as the
day goes by and I have to carve out time
to make orders on those cases
so our triage is basically emergency
cases cases that have statutory
deadlines that may be creeping up on us
and the divorce and parenting cases that
don't have statutory deadlines and
that's simply how we manage it day to
day in the Family Division and to a
lesser degree in the district division
thank you judge Garner
even even if our judicial head count
were where it needed to be in terms of
the way to caseload
we would not be adequately serving the
citizens of New Hampshire the people of
New Hampshire if we did not augment our
court staff
and uh I'd like to have judge king talk
about
the pressures that we are facing like
every other employer in our state with
respect to current vacancies and the
effects that that has on our ability to
to
um
for for the judges to do their jobs and
for the people to um
receive receive the services that that
they expect from our judiciary
so needless to say during the pandemic
we averaged about 70 to 75 percent of
our staff showing up on any given day
that was a tremendous pressure now that
we're sort of on the back side of that
our biggest challenge is that we're just
not competitive the judicial branch is
not competitive with starting wages our
starting wage for a quarter system two
which is an entry level position is
around 15 an hour uh after union dues I
think it's a it's 14 and change we
currently as of this morning have 39
full-time vacant staff positions most of
which have been posted for an extended
period of time three just in the Concord
circuit court court assistant threes
which are not entry levels those are the
next step up that we we just haven't
even had any applications for people
aren't applying to Workforce at those
wages so today we have 37 full-time
vacant positions and three part-time
vacant positions out of 359 total
positions so even at the positions that
are authorized notwithstanding that the
weighted caseload study reflects that we
need another 30 30 plus we have more
than 10 percent of our seats that are
vacant and absent some relief in the
budget for our wage restructuring
they're going to continue to be vacant
and if we don't have staff to process
the orders and get them out it's one
thing for a judge to hold a hearing sign
the order you may see another two to
three weeks before that order gets out
the door because we don't have staff to
process and I'm sure you've heard from
from constituents that that's the case
and that's our reality and our staff
work really really hard
um
and we offer great benefits but we're
finding that the the Millennials don't
care about health insurance because
they're probably on their parents health
insurance or they're not going to get
sick anyway so they don't need health
insurance they just want to know what am
I going to be paid an hour and we have
literally lost folks who have gone to
Dunkin Donuts and fast food restaurants
because they pay more an hour that's
that's our reality
so finally page slide 34 is a summary of
part of our budget request that is in
reflects what we learn from our
evidence-based way to caseload
as to judges you will see that of the 17
you'll recall
judges that the study identified we've
requested seven in in the superior court
of the three and a half uh judges that
were identified as needed we've
requested one in terms of Court staff 31
new clerical staff in the Circuit Court
in one new clerk in the circuit court
and in the Superior Court 4 News
clerical staff and one new law Clerk
so that is a summary the way the
caseload study I'm now going to ask
judge king to give a breakdown of some
statistics relating to the Family
Division
yeah I'm not sure what the Committees
want to hear so I'm happy to not do
anything I put together a few statistics
that I thought you might find
interesting I've already mentioned the
the volume of cases the and those are in
the slides
I want to make the point that
I've already talked about the turnover
in judges but 25 of our full-time judges
have been appointed since 2018 so more
than half our bench has been on the
bench less than five years so these are
Judges that are still in the process of
learning to be judges some of them have
come to us as prosecutors some have come
from various law practices and they have
to be trained as judge Garner said to
learn the breadth of the jurisdiction in
the circuit court so that they're
fungible and we can move them from
location to location
um
the judges are often in the courtrooms
kind of on their own in the circuit
court if you go to a superior court
you'll see a court monitor which is the
person who's with the judge responsible
to make sure the record's running
properly and has headphones on to make
sure everything's functional
our judges are often responsible for
turning the recorders on and off which
are not located on the bench they're
somewhere else or the court security
officers turn them on or off we we don't
have court monitors and our judges don't
have law Clerks so in the Superior Court
in the Supreme Court there are a law
clerks who are lawyers who assist with
writing orders doing research our judges
are on their own to do that we have
three staff attorneys to service roughly
60 judicial officers in the circuit
court and so you can expect that they
don't have a lot of time to be sitting
in on hearings and helping to write
orders when the pandemic started and we
moved to more remote hearings our
costs for telephone was going through
the roof and so we immediately began to
track the number of hearings and the
number of remote hearings and I thought
you might find this statistic
interesting since mid-march of 2020 in
the Circuit Court as of the end of
February Circuit Court judges have
conducted 469 532 hearings
of those two hundred and two thousand
four hundred and twenty three had at
least one party who participated
remotely either by telephone or by video
so about 43 percent but almost 470 000
hearings since March of 2020.
most of the folks who come to the
Circuit Court don't have attorneys we
call them self-represented litigants
about 85 percent of parenting divorce
cases have at least one unrepresented
party
that has its own challenges
and of all of the appeals that the
Supreme Court gets about 30 percent of
the total number come out of the Family
Division
so it's a small number in terms of the
gross number of cases but a lot of those
cases get appealed and 40 or so of those
are termination of parental rights cases
judge Garner talked about some cases
move quickly some take longer in 2014 we
had some law students for the summer and
we wanted to try to see if we could come
up with data points that were common
across divorce parenting cases that
caused them to be open longer than a
year so we looked at all of the cases
that were disposed between January and
December of 2014 which was 7 500 cases
roughly
of those cases 50 percent closed within
three months so from the time the case
was open the time it closed three months
seventy percent were closed within six
months 80 percent within nine months and
87 percent were closed within a year and
that's sort of our goal with a new
divorce cases from open to disposition
is a year we hope that more than 90
percent close within that time frame
um
most cases get resolved fairly quickly
in the Family Division
so there are some that don't and that go
on for years there are some cases that
have hundreds and hundreds of pleadings
those are the cases that I think you've
been hearing about in some of those in
your committees and that's just the
reality of the circuit court it's not
one size doesn't fit all
um
so I think those are the numbers I
wanted to talk about
Mr chairman to anticipate another area
of Interest based on our conversation I
know Rules of Evidence and evidentiary
issues in Family Division has been a
concern to to the Committees so I would
like to ask judge Garner to discuss that
if that's appropriate yes thank you
judge thank you
we think in terms of admissibility of
evidence and really that just means
what is the court allowed to consider
what is the court not going to consider
in terms of being a gatekeeper for what
we hope is going to be reliable evidence
the
question of the Rules of Evidence in
Family Division is as I understand the
subject of some proposed legislation so
let me try to give you a background and
if you'll indulge me I'll give you some
perspective in terms of what the reasons
might be
that might cause you to think carefully
about that sort of a proposal
currently the rules of evidence and I
brought my book with me it's a desk copy
that they give us we all have it
as lawyers we were trained in it from
law school and it is for those of us who
hear a lot of District division cases
criminal cases particularly everyone in
Superior Court
they live by the rules of evidence it's
a daily thing for them in Family
Division
it's not so much that way and
particularly in domestic relations cases
which are divorce parenting support
cases paternity
and I can lump domestic violence cases
in with that the Rules of Evidence don't
apply
and the Authority for that is a series
of Supreme Court decisions that actually
go back at least 80 years
and so there's a culture that these
sorts of cases do not receive the strict
treatment of the Rules of Evidence in
terms of the judge's decision whether to
admit certain evidence
or certain other kinds of evidence we
have discretion
the Family Division rules
carry on that that feature of our
practice that the Rules of Evidence
don't strictly apply but the Family
Division rules it's a rule 2.2 also
provide that the trial judge in their
discretion can utilize The Rules of
Evidence in order to create an orderly
predictable and fair kind of a
proceeding so that's available to us
in addition The Rules of Evidence
themselves carry a long list of
exemptions under rule 1101 and among
those exemptions from The Rules of
Evidence are Domestic Relations cases so
that's the current law The Rules of
Evidence don't apply the court in in
some cases can use them but I would
suggest only consistent with an
agreement if there are attorneys
typically representing both sides
because the Rules of Evidence are
complicated
and their application is often highly
technical
and the results are not always intuitive
this makes them a challenge for folks
who are representing themselves and it
makes it a challenge for folks who are
represented by an attorney with a
self-represented litigant on the other
side
so
the cases that tell us that the Rules of
Evidence don't apply in these kinds of
cases don't embellish much about the
reasons why that should be
but I'll share with you my perspective
based on my experience about what those
reasons might be
first are the rules of evidence are
really a tool for trial lawyers
they're a tool to create a reliable
gatekeeping process so that the fact
finder typically a jury in those cases
have reliable evidence to consider and
don't have unreliable evidence
trial lawyers live by the rules of
evidence judges in jury courts and
judges in criminal cases including
judges in the district Division and
circuit court apply the Rules of
Evidence have to be careful about them
and take that obligation very seriously
there are no juries in circuit court and
there are no juries in the Family
Division in circuit court and so at
least that part of it isn't really
necessary
Family Division cases and I'm thinking
mostly now Domestic Relations divorce
and parenting cases also have a couple
of unique features that I think
undermine the reason that might support
applying the rules of evidence in a
strict way the first of these is that
our court
tries its best to make our process user
friendly for those who are coming to
court for orders
and tries its best to make the process
as non-adversarial as possible partly
because often these folks who are in
front of the court on day one are going
to have parenting responsibilities for
children after the case is over and we
want to make sure that as difficult as
that case is for them we don't make it
more difficult by imposing on them
certain procedural strictures that they
may be unable to meet and that may
generate a result that at least they
will feel at some level wasn't a fair
result because of the application of
these rules
finally
divorce and parenting cases often take
um
often obligate the court to take into
account what's going to happen in the
future
if we're going to create a property
distribution or alimony or certainly
parenting orders that are going to be in
place from the time of the final decree
on
we have to take a Long View in terms of
what's going to happen what are the
likelihoods what are the parents parties
expectations and planning for that sort
of a thing really doesn't have much to
do with what actually happened the Rules
of Evidence are designed to provide
reliable evidence about what actually
happened and that certainly is part of
what we have to do but it's not the
whole picture in these kinds of cases we
have to take into account some planning
element for the future for these parties
lives that are being deconstructed and
rearranged by this process
and the Rules of Evidence aren't
necessarily helpful for them we want to
give the parties the opportunity to tell
us what their concerns are to develop a
plan for the future and to provide
evidence that would support that plan
not necessarily evidence that would be
reliable to a fact finder but evidence
it would be reliable for someone who's
planning the future of this family in
one way or another judge excuse me for a
minute being passed around to some cards
for members of the two committees if
they have questions as well for them to
write them down and then when you have
please send them back and chairman Lynn
is sorting them by question type sorry
sir carry on wonderful thank you and I
might add too that um
Richard has my email so if you think of
something after the hearing that you
think I can weigh in on in terms of our
practice or our challenges or a court
process please let him know he'll send
it on to me I'll be more than happy to
respond
then
there are some practical reasons I think
that the imposition of the Rules of
Evidence might be of some concern to
those of us who hear these sorts of
cases in Family Division
particularly if you have a situation
where one party is represented by
Council and the other party is not
represented by Council beside this
represented is going to start out with
some Advantage there if the Rules of
Evidence are being applied an attorney
May well have an obligation to their
client to try to take advantage of the
rules of evidence to the extent possible
that's part of our adversarial system
and there's nothing wrong with that
unless one party is so disadvantaged by
their lack of knowledge about the rules
or their lack of experience about the
rules that they simply are a target for
the imposition of the rules in a strict
way and requiring the rules to apply
makes it difficult for the court to
generate some kinds of information in
that context
further in the situation where both
parties are self-represented and that's
I think
rough guess more than 50 percent of our
cases divorce and parenting cases
involve folks who are representing
themselves each of them
applying the Rules of Evidence to those
sorts of cases creates what I think is
likely an insurmountable challenge for
them and it also begs the question of
who's going to
be the gatekeeper there in a very
practical way
if one party is testifying in a way or
submitting evidence
that is clearly contrary to The Rules of
Evidence
the judge is faced with a choice if the
other party is not objecting does the
court weigh in and say you can't do that
that feels to the party reasonably feels
to the party as though the Court's
simply not interested in listening to
what they have to say or in considering
their evidence
so there are sort of a myriad of
practical problems that go along with
that as someone who is trained in the
rules and who
worked with the rules as an attorney
doing trials and as someone who still
applies the rules in District division
in criminal cases
I have tremendous respect for the rules
of evidence and I think there's a role
for them I'm concerned that the strict
imposition of the Rules of Evidence May
extend our cases these sorts of cases in
Family Division may not really be a good
fit for these sorts of cases in Family
Division and will create impediments and
costs to the parties both in terms of
the time and in terms of some
dissatisfaction with the result if it if
it appears to them that the result is
based on a technical application
they're not going to be happy about the
results if it appears and I think
studies that we've learned about have
shown this if the parties feel as though
the process is fair they've been
listened to they've been understood the
court has taken into account their
concerns and their own point of view
then the outcome is slightly less
critical to them it's the process itself
that we're trying to make as Fair as
possible to these folks who are often
representing themselves and the in my
view the marginal benefit of imposing
The Rules of Evidence is probably
outweighed in the long term
by the the difficulties that it creates
for folks within that system and the
difficulties it creates in achieving the
goals that we'd like to try to meet
so that's my practical take I want to
clarify that I'm not speaking on behalf
of the judicial branch this is this is
my read based on my experience judge
Gunner um
chairman Lynn has been sorting the cards
by type and I've asked him if he has
cards on this particular issue of Rules
of Evidence this would be a good time to
take questions on that subject you just
spoke of thank you
I might mention while he's sorting
through those cards that if you have
questions about the Rules of Evidence
generally and even specifically
I don't consider myself an expert in the
Rules of Evidence by any means but you
have an expert sitting here in this room
and I suspect that representative Lynn
would be more than happy to sort of give
you the Practical impact of the Rules of
Evidence at any level
well thank you
I wonder if I'm how quickly I would be
reversed though but yeah
so you know I
um I guess I would um
in trying to follow up on what you were
just speaking of uh judge judge Garner
um one one questioner says if the rules
of evidence do not do not apply then
does the court rely on hearsay in its
orders
um and I wonder if you could maybe just
elaborate on that a bit it's a
complicated answer and and I don't like
to say maybe but
if the Rules of Evidence don't apply the
court has discretion to determine what's
relevant and to determine what's
material and helpful to the court in
making its decision
there are on and I should mention just
by way of background that
hearsay is a vast part of the Rules of
Evidence so even applying the Rules of
Evidence there's some statements that
are not hearsay because of the reason
that they're offered and there are a
long list of exceptions to the rule
against hearsay which cover many of the
kinds of evidence that people would
submit that would be admissible even
Under The Rules of Evidence
I'll tell you when my personal take is
when I have a hearsay objection I'm
going to be guided by the rules to begin
with if it's not hearsay then I'm going
to overrule the objection if it is
hearsay I'll run through in my head what
the exceptions might be
and if there are no exceptions that
particularly cover it I'll ask myself
what are the independent indicio
reliability about this particular piece
of evidence whether it's a statement or
whether it's a document is there
something about it either the context or
the content or plugging it into that
piece of the case it makes it reliable
in a way that we wouldn't ordinarily
rely on on a blank statement
and if it is then I'll probably let it
in so the answer is that hearsay some
kinds of hearsay is admissible is
admissible under the rules under one of
the exceptions and I don't expect that
the Family Division in these sorts of
cases
would allow um
would disallow evidence that would come
in under the rules I think if anything
we're going to expand a little bit
beyond the rules to get information that
we're greedy for frankly in in looking
to make good decisions and to help these
folks for the rest of their lives so
that's my maybe answer okay thank you
um and let me just address this to
really all any of you've uh who may want
to answer it the question is without
Rules of Evidence how do you address
possible mental health concerns as
related to the best interest of the
child
uh in making custody and or parenting
time decisions
sure
I think actually there's some potential
for the Rules of Evidence to be an
impediment to that sort of an inquiry
medical records of
therapy or counseling records those
sorts of things
are often the best evidence that might
bear on that kind of a question
and the Rules of Evidence might
sometimes exclude those because of the
lack of a foundation or lack of
authentication whereas if the parties
agree that a document is something that
it is what it purports to be and it's
relevant then the court would typically
take that into account and probably
allow it to be marked and probably
consider it I should mention as a
footnote because we're talking about
medical or counseling records that the
provisions of the rules of evidence that
relate to privileges
attorney-client privilege doctor patient
privileged counselor therapist privilege
those carry on and those are applied
even in the cases where the Rules of
Evidence don't strictly apply so there
may be issues related to privilege that
might keep something out of that nature
but the authentication issues we're
likely to get past if the parties agree
that the document is what it is
this is a little a little bit different
but I think it generally goes to the
sort of the issues of efficiency in the
judicial branch and the and I'm I'm sort
of recasting the question but this
questioner raises concerns about
um
delays in family cases and
particularly focuses on the fact that
apparently that in many cases the the
presiding judge
changes
during the course of the proceeding here
it is the ledge two or three times
during the course of a proceeding could
you just kind of any of you really just
sort of explain what when in a
particular case is it normally assigned
to a particular judge throughout the
case or is it or does the judge do the
judges change hearing to hearing and if
so when when is that likely to happen
yeah so in a perfect world
representative Lynn
a Family Division was designed to be one
family one judge so the the concept was
a judge would be assigned to a case and
it would be if there was a divorce case
pending that they would be the judge if
there was a related abuse neglect it
would be the same judge there was a
juvenile delinquency case would be the
same judge but the reality is that we
have a lot of turnover in our bench we
have to move judges around because
on any given day I may get a call in the
morning or the night before that a
judges out for covet or other related
reasons and we have to shuffle judges
around so
I think in a best case scenario it would
be a judge that would carry through the
life of the case but some of these cases
go on for years and years too so a judge
May retire and somebody else has to come
in I just had a case literally that was
the case had been pending for 20 years
the judge retired and one of the lawyers
asked that the judge be specially
assigned in his retirement to hear the
case and I said because he's because the
judge has been hearing this case for 20
years they said he's retired I mean I
can't force him to come out of
retirement to hear this case
um that's an extreme example but the
reality is that with a turnover and
judges and judges covering multiple
locations that it's it's not possible to
have one judge for one case straight
through from beginning to end and you
know just to sort of follow up on this
because I think that that's there are a
number of questions here that sort of
focus on how long Family Division cases
take and I know you mentioned before
that that the typical and perhaps a vast
majority of let's say divorce cases are
concluded within a year can you just
give us without getting into the details
of any particular case but can you just
give us sort of a um an overview of of
what what are the situations that cause
a case to go on for like 20 years as you
just said what are the what are the sort
of dynamics of the situation that causes
that kind of thing to happen and what
and it's and is there something the
judge can do to stop that yeah I'll let
judge Garner handle like this
I I can't think of any offhand that are
20 years but
but I think every judge who works in the
Family Division has cases that have gone
on longer than they should have gone on
in the ideal world
some of those cases too are cases in
which some of those cases too are cases
in which you've gotten to a final
hearing within the period you would hope
certainly six months nine months a year
if it's a really contested case
final orders have been entered but the
case may have been brought forward by
one of the parties
and this that's not something we can
control there are legal standards that
in parenting issues that make the burden
of proof more difficult if you bring a
case forward from a final parenting plan
but that doesn't prevent folks from
bringing them forward and there are
quite legitimate and reasonable issues
too such as a proposed relocation of the
children's residents that could prompt
the case to be brought forward so I
think it's important to distinguish
between the question of how long the
Family Division gets to a final decree
the first time the case is filed and
then how we manage a case once it's
brought forward because it can be
brought forward it seems endlessly I'm
sure it seems endless to the parties but
it can be brought forward almost at
infinitum until typically the children
reach age of 18.
um I would say that there are a couple
of issues that tend to come up that may
cause some delays inherently
if the parties are having trouble
managing the exchange of information we
have a mandatory Discovery rule
sometimes it's difficult for folks to
get around to doing that
if the parties are
at loggerheads in terms of the parenting
orders even if there are temporary
orders in place if they're having
trouble complying or their motions for
contempt about non-compliance that can
always delay the process because we'll
schedule a hearing on those motions once
the motion and objection is filed
it happens sometimes that um in
complicated cases particularly
complicated Financial cases they'll have
attorneys on both sides they have to do
a lot of Discovery in those cases they
may have to engage experts to testify to
provide opinions that process in itself
tends to take longer than the case might
otherwise require those are inherent
issues with every case and the faces of
them change and there are always cases
that have a combination of more than one
of those features that just make it
difficult to say to the parties and have
them say to the court now we're ready
now we're ready to schedule a final
hearing we've done what we have to do
we're prepared let's go forward and
typically the court is not
likely we're going to try to time the
scheduling of a final hearing at a point
where we can trust that the parties are
really ready and they need the time
because if
if the case really doesn't need a full
day and we schedule a full day and it
turns out that day or the day before
that it didn't need a full day and
they've settled it we've just spent a
day that we may not be able to fill in
with other hearings so we we treat our
time as valuable and we try to get the
litigants to look at it the same way and
everyone tries to be practical and
realistic about how long the case will
take let me follow up on that from
another card on the subject we're on
right now in terms of
length of time we already spoke of there
were not enough judges we it looks like
are going to get some more of the ones
we need but what about one of the
litigants who's turning the process
whether it is the wealthy person who can
pay a lawyer to tie the other one up
with endless motions or somebody who is
pro se but has read too much and doesn't
understand enough and is doing the same
thing when is it proper for the judge to
come in and say you're abusing the
process
in that situation once it becomes
apparent that one side or the other is
is dragging their heels
the Court's primary focus is going to be
on setting deadlines to get the
discovery complete once the discovery is
complete there's really there should be
no impediment to scheduling a final
hearing and when they've completed
Discovery they know what the issues are
going to be and they can tell us if they
need a two-hour final hearing or half a
day or a full day final hearing so the
court I think has an obligation at some
point in the in that's in that stage
when that's becoming apparent to begin
to schedule hearings to set those
deadlines to make sure that if there are
if there's a need for orders on
Discovery those orders get out right
away and the parties know what their
face it I think most attorneys who are
experienced in this area will tell you
that
the prime time to settle cases is when
you get that final hearing schedule
that's what you're preparing for for the
client there that's when the expenses
are going to go up that's when the
uncertainty can be nipped in the bud by
a settlement and that's the best time to
settle the cases and we're always
looking for ways to get them close to
that moment the follow-up to that is
that if family and divorce issues are
not that legislatively mandated priority
is one of the ways to speed up a divorce
case for the legislature to make that a
mandatory priority with a follow-up I'll
put in but if everything becomes
mandated nothing is then pretty soon
I don't disagree with that last part of
it it's really a policy question whether
you impose those sorts of deadlines on
us in terms of those cases but
in my experience because of the
unpredictability of the cases and really
the wide spectrum
I think there are likely cases that that
could never be done
properly and fully Within
any sort of mandated time constraint
there will be those exceptions as judge
king mentioned most of our cases get
resolved one way or the other we funnel
folks into mediation through the first
appearance program that's been very
successful particularly in resolving the
parenting cases that's a that's a high
priority for us is to get folks into
that process of working together to try
to settle the cases as early as we can
it's just these outlier cases that are
extremely difficult for whatever reason
extremely time consuming those are going
to be very difficult to manage within a
mandated period of time
thank you I wonder if these two sort of
related questions the first uh is would
better training of Circuit Court judges
reduce the hours needed by judges to
deal with contested family cases
um
uh by by reducing the need for
re-hearings that kind of thing and then
the second sort of related question is
can you uh
uh
take just a bit of time to explain to us
the the uh the evaluation process of
Judges how judges are evaluated and how
often that happens that kind of thing
foreign
the first question deals with training
and that's the responsibility of the
administrative office and we don't have
a one-size-fits-all for judicial
training sometimes we'll get two or
three judges at once uh and we can put
together a more robust training program
we're in the process right now of
training Judge Amy Manchester she got
appointed as a one-off judge and so
we've cobbled together a training
schedule for her
um it's it's harder to bring in outside
resources for one judge but we we can
never do enough training we do a
Judicial training every other month for
all of our judges in the Circuit Court
it could be a topic of any of the three
divisions we don't have money to hire
outside presenters so we do our own
homemade presentations using our judges
and staff attorneys and Outsiders as we
can get them but I think we can always
do more training the second question was
could you
yeah that's a creature of Statute um
we're required every three years to do a
evaluation of all of our judges uh we
had a committee that took a deep dive a
few years ago representative Smith was
on the committee uh we changed the
instrument that we use to do the
evaluations we now do them
electronically using SurveyMonkey and we
Post in the courthouses and in bar news
when a certain group of Judges is being
evaluated and it's open to anyone who
wants to complete the evaluation we
typically get anywhere from 30 to 50
evaluations back for a judge and then
it's my job to analyze those and go
through them with the judge and use
those as a tool to help performance
going forward
by and large the judicial and the
results not by judge but the results
each year are made available to the
governor's office office the House and
Senate and are on our website in terms
of how many judges were evaluated what
the mean and median scores were for all
judges and by and large our judges even
the judges in the Family Division do
pretty well on their performance
evaluations
yes
as someone who's been through that
process quite a bit I would just point
out that
judges don't often get feedback about
how they're doing
that just for whatever reason
um
we're somewhat isolated and attorneys
particularly aren't going to come up and
tell us often that we've done a terrible
job and this is really what we need to
refocus on and maybe get some training
on
there is a component of the evaluation
that's a self-evaluation and I've always
found that extremely valuable because it
gives me a chance to sort of second
guess what I've been doing and maybe
identify areas that I can do better and
I think we're still doing it the
evaluation process generates
a series of particular comments from the
evaluators they've been edited so
they're sort of anonymous but comments
that can be really helpful for a judge
reading over and understanding how
someone else perceived how they did
their job for me both of those
components
um sort of take the edge off what
otherwise might be sort of an anxious
process of getting evaluated but it does
generate great information it's helpful
for us in our efforts to do our job
better
thank you that's a parallel to that
could you speak to
um the judicial review I mean this this
is a bit of training but I mean the
disciplinary process
of when it is alleged that a judge has
really crossed the line
so I'm not sure if I understand the
question Mr chairman but there were
there were two two avenues that that can
go if I know a situation where there is
an allegation that the judges in an
order made an error of law
that goes to Chief Justice McDonald's
court and they review that as part of
the Appellate process and they either
affirm the judge or they reverse the
judge the second component deals more
with behavioral issues on the part of a
judge which is maybe what you're getting
at there is a Judicial conduct committee
uh Robert middleholtzer is the chairman
of that it has a number of members both
from the public
and the court system and they meet
monthly and they review complaints if
you will against judges and I I get
copies of all of them as they make their
way through to the end of the process
and by and large
most of the complaints against judges
that I see in the Circuit Court are
Judges who sit in primarily in the
Family Division they involve mostly
divorce parenting cases and for the most
part they go to the merits of the case
that the you know the judge came up with
the wrong decision if you will which is
really something that should go to the
Appellate Court if that's the issue if
it rises to a serious enough level it's
it becomes a public complaint and
there's a whole process for that for the
judicial conduct committee and they too
report their findings at the end of
every year how many complaints they
received how many resulted in certain
outcomes so that's that's a public and
transparent process the complaints are
confidential until they erase the level
of a complaint by the committee could
you try to remember a recent year and
give us the number of complaints and the
number that were
um
dismissed for not being what would go
forward with any action I I'm losing the
term I'm striving for here yeah since
that's a that's a function that's
outside of the judicial branch I don't
have those numbers at hand I I they are
available there's a link on the Supreme
Court on our judicial branch website to
the judicial conduct committee and I
think those statistics are available but
I'll follow up and see if I can get the
most recent report
but this is an external it sounds like
when you said you didn't have that
information that means this is somewhat
of an external
Review Committee it is external to the
official Branch it's not the guys
evaluating their themselves correct okay
uh this is this is I think an important
topic would you please talk about
mediation and its effect on caseloads
and the weighted caseload study are
there impediments to structural
mediation such as not enough mediators
or insufficient funding
so I can start and maybe judge Garner
can talk more specifically about Family
Division the office of mediation and
arbitration works out of the judicial
branch and we have mediation pretty much
across all case types some are available
at no charge to litigants some have a
sliding scale I think in the Family
Division and I think all judges strongly
encourage various forms of alternative
dispute resolution mediation being the
primary one it's required in all cases
involving parenting cases where the
parents are required to go to mediation
pretty much out of the gate to try to
get those issues resolved and it's
highly effective I mean the the success
rates are are pretty high in the Circuit
Court we also have something called
neutral case evaluation
which has kind of fallen off because we
rely on judicial officers to do it but
neutral case evaluation is where a judge
who is not going to hear the case sits
down for a half day or a day with the
parties depending on the complexity of
the case and you sort of have a almost a
mini trial without Witnesses and at the
end of the process the judge tells the
parties how he or she thinks if they
were to have heard the case it would
come out so just for example you know
let's say it's an alimony issue at the
end the judge says you know I think this
is a situation where if I were the judge
hearing this case based on what I've
heard I would be ordering alimony maybe
a case where the lawyer's been telling
his or her client you're going to pay
alimony and they're saying no I'm not
and the lawyer's saying yes you are and
so you go to neutral case evaluation and
experienced judicial officer you know
being versed in the law and having heard
the facts
says what they think would happen
sometimes that is a really good way to
get those more difficult cases to settle
I did a neutral case evaluation during
covid in a trust docket case that
involved multi-millions of dollars we
had lots of lawyers we started at 8 30
in the morning I left the law office at
8 30 that night it was a Friday night we
spent 12 hours and ultimately and this
was a case that had gone to mediation
and and didn't settle ultimately because
I was a judge and I have experience in
this area of the law
and I was able to tell the parties what
I think is going to happen in this case
including how the legal fees which were
in the millions of dollars might get
apportioned if I were to hear the case
the parties were able to work with their
lawyers and get that case resolved
that case was scheduled for an eight-day
trial in two weeks and so I called the
judge when I got home that night and
said you owe me one because I just
settled an eight-day trial for you but
neutral case evaluation is a very good
tool and we would like to expand that in
the Family Division as we have the
resources to do it
perfect
let me just supplement a little bit with
a specific procedure that applies in
divorce cases with children and
parenting cases
when the petition is filed and assuming
that there are no emergency orders that
are involved the parties are sent to
what we call the first appearance
session
pre-covered we were doing these sessions
live so typically in the courtroom where
I'm able to sit in Laconia we can seat
about 25 people we'd have 10 or 12
couples come in and they would get
directly from me or from whatever judge
was doing it that day a basic
description of the process the procedure
of this involved mention of the
mandatory Discovery Rule and a lot of
information about mediation and the
presumption is and was from that process
that unless there was a reason to be
exempt from it the parties would go to
mediation before they would come back to
court for any contested hearings and we
had great success at that I should
mention as a footnote that there is an
exception for cases where there's a
domestic violence protective order in
effect in those cases we can send the
parties to mediation but only if they
both agree either one of them gets a
veto power and those mediation sessions
always occur at the courthouse we've
been doing the first appearance sessions
remotely now because there's a video
that the judicial branch created for us
we've candidly with speakers who are a
lot more effective at it than I was
doing it live although I still think
there was some benefit to having it live
but it's been a great program and our
mediators
in a place like Laconia we've been using
the same mediators for years and they
are fully expert at what they do and
they're very nice people and they create
an atmosphere there's much more
congenial and productive than the sort
of formal courtroom atmosphere that
they're going to be facing if the
mediation doesn't work out so it's been
a great program and we completely
encourage it
so this uh one of the questions I think
this is this is a a point that needs to
be made
can you just explain to us let's talk
about I'm not talking about part-time
judges but a full-time judge can you
just explain our full-time judges
permitted to have any other employment
and are there any are there limits on a
judge's ability to earn income outside
of his or her judicial salary
uh
there is a limitation judges are allowed
to do
teaching I think is pretty much the only
outside employment that they're allowed
to do only with the permission written
permission of the Chief Justice and
their salary cannot exceed I think it's
15 of the judge's salary
um I just I can tell you from experience
the Circuit Court judges don't have time
to teach
um
I don't I'm not sure if we have any uh
active I think we may have some judges
who teach uh trial ad at the law school
some Superior Court judges and I think
we might have one circuit court judge
that does it but it's pretty Limited
can't practice law at all under rule 38
which is the code of judicial conduct
I want to follow up on the judicial
conduct committee uh the questionnaire
and I don't know if this is correct or
not I'll just read the card why do the
members of the judicial conduct
committee number one not have to take an
oath of office I'm not sure what that
means and secondly and I know the answer
to this one had there why do they have
their meetings in secret
well by rule the process is confidential
unless as I said earlier the complaint
the the cases risen to the level of a
complaint I have no idea whether they
take an oath of office or not
okay I don't know why they
I don't know why they would but they not
I don't know that they do or don't in
terms of meetings in secret
if I was accused of something I would
want it to be substantiated before I
read about it in the union later
you know you wouldn't read about in the
union leader until it was risen to the
level of the complaint and then the
process is the judge gets the complaint
and has 30 days to respond to it and
then the committee sort of takes off
from there so at the end of the case the
judge always gets a copy and the
resolution but
um you wouldn't want a judge to know in
the middle of a case that someone would
file a complaint so there's two sides to
that thank you
so
um
this this uh the questioner asks why are
Judges not ending cases
um sooner and allowing frivolous motions
um that's that's the question I so I put
it to to you uh you know what is that is
that true and uh what what you know what
why what are the processes for for sort
of
truncating cases that seem to go on
forever
the question of frivolity I think may be
something that's uh in the eye of the
beholder
but we have an obligation to move the
cases along and to provide good orders
within a reasonable and fair period of
time
and so to the extent that motions to us
appear to be frivolous
will typically make a finding we may
make immediate rulings on those sorts of
motions so to convey the message at some
point in the process I think we have
authority although I think it's rarely
used
to limit A party's right to file
additional motions I don't know that
we're ever going to be able to justify
preventing a party from filing some
things that's an access to justice issue
that is really fundamental to what we do
but we can impose sanctions and we can
impose requirements on filings that will
to some degree enhance the likelihood
that the Motions are not going to be
frivolous in terms of resolving the
cases sooner
I think there are two processes there
one is the process of our workload
so
currently if you were to have a
pre-trial conference with us today and
you needed a full day final hearing
we're scheduling about three months out
so that's that's time you're going to
wait to get to that hearing with nothing
else going on
but there are also
cases in which we can intervene if you
will or help the parties in a direction
of mediation or neutral case evaluation
that may help the case get resolved
sooner it's in our interest and it's
certainly in the party's interests to
get cases resolved as soon as they can
be fairly resolved meaning that all the
relevant information is available to
them to present and meaning that they've
exhausted all the possibilities of
negotiation so I think we have a common
goal with folks in that our workload is
a bit of an impediment in terms of the
time we have available and the nature of
some of the cases makes it basically
challenging to get them ready for a
final Hearing in a in a brief period of
time
I wonder if the next question which I
think judge Garner you may have touched
on this a little bit earlier but
um could you could any of you really
give us your thoughts on what what would
be the effect
if that's a general matter in family law
cases the burden of proof were elevated
in other words instead of preponderance
of the evidence which is generally the
standard that applies it were elevated
to either clear and convincing evidence
or proof Beyond A Reasonable Doubt what
can you just tell us what your sense of
what the effect of that would be
the clear and convincing standard is
already in place in cases that are
brought forward on parenting issues so
under 461a 11 1 at least two of those
subsections require clear and convincing
evidence before the court can modify an
existing parenting plan so it's not a
standard that we're unused to
it's a I think a difficult standard to
articulate for uh for parties who are
self-represented
and
um
to some degree the there is no
particular burden of proof in the first
the first time around in Family Division
cases there's a presumption of joint
decision making there's a presumption
that regular and frequent contact with
children is consistent with their best
interests and the standard for orders
that relate to Children is what's in the
best interests of the child rather than
a formal assignment of burden of proof
to one side or the other
so I think it starts with a More Level
Playing Field if
there's no reason in my view to require
parties both to prove something by
clearing convincing evidence the first
time around the statutory standard in
for modification of parenting is there
because the legislature recognized that
stability is really important for
children they wanted to make it a little
more difficult for someone seeking to
modify a parenting plan to come back and
and get a modification so they impose
that standard under those two
subsections
so beyond a reasonable doubt I I won't
address that I
I don't know how that would work
um the next question I I think this is
really this is a value one why did the
court system not request in the budget
the number of Judges indicated by the
weighted case study
[Music]
it is about a question
um
we we and I want to be clear this is we
our request this year is a significant
step towards addressing or uh needs but
it's not the final step and we're also
mindful of the larger context in which
we operate and we try to be good
partners in state government and uh good
stewards of the taxpayers dollars
um and all of those factors played into
our ultimate decision to ask for seven
in the circuit court and one in the
Superior Court
thank you
um and and you know by the time we're
developing our next budget we'll have
better we'll have
good insight as to hopefully or how our
additional resources are helping our
caseload and we'll be able to come back
to the legislature again informed with
with whether what what further
additional needs we have
can um I wonder uh maybe this would be
for you judge king of the of the 126
000 or so uh
circuit court cases can you give us a
rough idea of approximately how many are
dcyf related in other words that have
the division
uh for children youth and families
involved uh at some level
so you
talking pretty much about abuse neglect
and and delinquency cases
um and so I'll use uh 2020 two numbers
uh
[Music]
looks like about
2600 cases in 2022 would have involved
the division directly
well and then there's another 560
determination of parental rights cases
which that's sort of the back end of the
abuse neglect typically so
um north of 3000 cases
thank you
I think on slide eight if you look at
the Circle to identified as juvenile
yep identifies the number of case
juvenile related cases for the years
that we use for the beta kids load study
um the next question uh do judges still
order
parent-child unification therapy and if
so why why or why not
thank you
[Music]
that process is not currently
unavailable to us
but there are some elements of the
process that make it extremely rare
if I understand the process it is that a
reunification therapist
is appointed presumably with the consent
of the parties but by order of the Court
to conduct a reunification therapy to
allow and enhance and encourage a child
to reunify with one parent the
question of the word reunification is a
bit ambiguous whether it means just some
regular contact or whether it means a
full reunification under a shared
residential schedule but it's a process
in which typically there are there's a
therapist or the child
there may be a therapist for the parent
but there's a reunification therapist
who provides the Forum and provides some
of the therapy and helps all of them
work together to try to reunify the
relationship
because it is
an intense pretty intense process it's I
think rarely used it's probably an
expensive process and I'll say as a
caveat I've never had a case where I've
actually presided over the process
although
um
is not completely unknown to me because
of some things that have come up in
other cases but I won't mention
specifically but it's a um
it's a process in which I think some of
the therapists have great faith and it
would be
just thinking globally it would be
something that would be used in the rare
occasion and often is virtually a last
resort when the relationship between a
parent and a child for whatever reason
is so distant and so is strange that
without professional input and
professional assistance it may not be
salvageable
so that's my quick take I'll know more
if I ever get to a series of hearings
that involve that but that's my
understanding of the process and and
some of the pitfalls
uh judge king I think this probably
would be the best the best address to
you um
you mentioned I think earlier in your
remarks that uh there were no more
marital Masters
um on the bench um
uh they that that many of them had
retired and then I apparently at some
point at some point later you mentioned
that um uh some marital masses had
become judges in fact I think judge
Garner so could you just can you just
kind of explain how I mean is it is that
a
a sort of usual course or when we did
have marital Masters was it was is that
something that you know to go from being
a marital Master to a judge to something
that happened in with some some
regularity
I think it was probably unheard of until
we created the Circuit Court back when
the Superior Court had jurisdiction over
divorces before you cleverly passed them
on to us
um
I think the mayoral Masters were
creation of the Superior Court initially
because the judges didn't want to hear
marital cases so they found a way to
have someone else hear them and then as
we rolled the Family Division out on by
Statute we began to inherit the superior
Court's marital Masters until July 1st
2011 as I said there were 13 left we got
them all
as part of House Bill 609 which was the
bill that created the Circuit Court in
2011 uh
under speaker O'Brien there was a
provision put into for an IDF that said
as a marital Masters term expires and
they were they were appointed for
five-year terms
or they retired they couldn't they they
would be converted to a Judicial
position as the budget allowed there
were three marital Masters in that one
year that 2011 window
whose terms expired David Forrest and
barber and Phil cross
those three marital Masters were
terminated their their positions were
ended and Barbara went into the
practices of law day Forest I think
taught at Keen for a while and Phil
cross became a mediator
the next but the next session of the
legislature we went back and we said can
we change that because that seems unfair
can we change it to when a judge retires
um or is not reappointed that the
position would convert and the statute
was amended so that marital Masters
terms could be extended if they wanted
to stay over the course of time marital
Mass has retired some then did apply to
become judges including judge Garner
judge Croc Phil cross applied for a
Judicial position he's now a judge Dave
Forrest is a judge Jen Lemire who I
think this committee's heard from on a
couple of occasions is a judge Bob Foley
was a marital Master he became a judge
he's now a retired judge
did I miss anyone
okay
and so Tom Cooper was the last marital
Master to retire he retired last year
and he is the one mayoral master that
still sits very occasionally he's been
great to cover for us when we've had a
coveted illness or something he's gone
and covered dockets for us but we're we
basically have no more marital Masters
left
um all right so
um
with the f um
with the efforts of Juvenile Diversion
do you see a reduction in uh the time
that that circuit court judges are
spending on juvenile related cases
so judge Ashley's the expert on that
she's the deputy administrative judge
and I know only from speaking with her
that the number of cases that actually
become cases now is has been decreased
dramatically because of the requirement
to have an evaluation done before the
charge can be filed and I think that's
made a big difference and I think it's
keeping a lot of kids out of court that
otherwise would find themselves tied up
in the in the judicial system I think
it's been a I think she would say it's
been a big success
I wonder if you could talk generally
about the use of guardian ad litem
Guardians Adel item in uh in family law
cases
before the Circuit Court came into being
Guardians ad litem were I think more
numerous than they are currently
there was a period of time when we had a
state fund that would pay some of the
fees for Guardians at Litem for folks
who were eligible for those kinds of
services
part of the creation of the Circuit
Court was to emphasize mediation as a
way to resolve cases and I think the
theory was that if cases were mediated
and resolved by agreement between the
parties we wouldn't need Guardians I'd
lie to the extent that they were sort of
the rule of the day in the days when
these cases were heard in Superior Court
there are still Guardians at Litem who
are practicing there are not nearly as
many as there were and the state fund
that used to pay for their fees for
eligible parties is now hasn't been in
place for a number of years
so they potentially have a role to play
as a as a judge who hears a lot of these
cases and as someone who did Guardian Ad
Litem work when I was in private
practice I think there's a role for them
they can be very helpful in the right
case they are
simply because of the finances only now
available to folks who can afford to pay
for their fees
and those fees can be significant
particularly Guardians ad litem who are
practicing attorneys will they may not
charge exactly what they would charge a
private client but
um they need to charge enough money to
make the work attractive to them and
that's what they do so we have Guardians
that light them available in Laconia
we've got three or four on a list they
get some cases but we always have to be
very careful with the parties to let
them know that the fees are on them and
and there's no other way to pay for
those Services I could go into
endless detail about the role and the
history but I think the short answer is
that Guardians at Litem are available
but only to a certain select few of our
of our litigants
why are the members of family law
committee not required to serve a number
of hours observing what really happens
in court
stay tuned we're going on field trips
thank you
this question I think is
um I I think it's probably something
that would be important to discuss
um can you just whoever would be the
most uh the most appropriate one to
answer this but can you just talk
generally about the effect of delay
in in coming to an accurate you know an
accurate decision in the case in other
words you know we've we're obviously as
time goes by memories fade that kind of
thing but in the particularly in the
family law context
um can you can you talk about that a
little bit how delay and and uh and
having cases adjudicated how that can
affect the accuracy of of fact finding
you mean delay during the process of
getting to the final hearing or delay
after the final hearings taken place
well I guess both really maybe uh but
but probably more more of the former
than the latter but really both
most of our divorce cases are based on
irreconcilable differences now there are
foregrounds available but they're rarely
pled and rarely uh hotly litigated and
so the question of delay comes up if
there are changes in values for a
property that's going to be distributed
for example the parties separate and a
year later the house is worth something
different than it was that can create an
issue for parties depending on how the
market is doing
there is delay affects children
in practical ways children whose parents
have separated and whose future with
either parent may be a little bit
uncertain creates anxiety and problems
for them behavioral problems for them
that's sort of a dramatic impact of the
delay in the process
some delay in the process is inherent
because the parties still need to
reassess what they have and and do their
Discovery and be prepared for a final
hearing and and to look into negotiated
settlement but delay in the process is
almost
never a good thing unless something is
happening in the meantime to help the
parties toward resolution so if a case
is going to go out several months
without anything being scheduled we'll
talk to the parties about using the rest
of their mediation time
if they haven't used all of their
mediation time or we might arrange for a
neutral case evaluation once the
discovery is done to give them a handle
on what to expect
so it is
um
detrimental to the parties emotionally
it can be detrimental to the family and
it can make it can make valuation issues
taking place months after the moment of
separation more difficult for the court
but really more the former than the
latter we can manage the valuation
issues already it's the it's the sort of
ongoing anxiety and
chronic emotional outfall that we really
worry about for folks
and I should say that's true after the
final hearing has taken place too that's
a terrible time for folks to be waiting
for their orders and we would always
like to get the orders out as soon as
possible as soon as we can review the
evidence write the order and be
thoughtful and careful about it
so I wonder if I just really addressed
to to uh to any of you but um as you I
think as you both as you've some of you
have reflected on before
um
the family cases it was my experience
when I was in the judicial branch and
I'm sure it's your family cases are the
ones that tend to generate the most
complaints to us as legislators to the
judicial conduct committee
um you know complaints in the media that
kind of I wonder if you could and I
should say my understanding and correct
me if things have changed in the last
three and a half years but the
overwhelming majority of complaints that
are made to the judicial conduct
Committee in family cases are found to
be non-meritorious there are that's not
to say all of them but but the vast
majority of them but I wonder if you
could offer any insights as to why you
think that is that that um
family cases in particular tend to
generate so much angst
I'll just talk generically and I'm not
the expert on the marital law as judge
Garner is if I've been a judge for 33
years nobody would want me hearing the
divorce case it's outside of my area of
expertise but I do review all of the
complaints because I get them at the end
of the process and I think they're just
there as you well know representative
Lynn they're high emotion cases people
are very set in their ways they feel
very strongly about their position for
good reasons and when the case doesn't
go the way they wanted to then the
they're angry at the judge they're angry
at the process they file appeals they
file complaints and
we they want us to make their lives
better and that's and we just don't have
that ability to put their lives back
together that the judges just can't do
that and you know as you heard divorce
cases in the Superior Court when you
were judged I worked with judge
Manchester this morning we were going
over the code of judicial conduct and
we're talking about
um disqualification and we're talking
about the judicial conduct committee and
the Tapley case is the case that we
train on and that was your case that
went to the Supreme Court and I think
you had
four if not five JCC complaints filed
against you in that case and you stayed
with the case because you felt you
didn't have a conflict in the Supreme
Court affirmed you but you you certainly
have a sense for how emotionally
draining these cases are and how people
you know sometimes file complaints out
of out of anger because the case didn't
go the way they wanted it to go
I gotta read it our judges paid a salary
or is there a financial incentive for
them to hear more emotions in a case
so I can answer that question I think
everyone don't mind Mr chairman I'll go
back and just add something to the
previous the answer is yes we are paid a
salary and no there is no Financial
incentive for us to have more motions
filed ask
um I just wanted to add that
I think some of the difficulties
um
that are inherent with Family Division
cases and particularly parenting cases
come about because
the relationship typically at one time
was a good relationship between the
parties if they have children or if
they've been married for a long time and
now
something's gone wrong sometimes
something terribly wrong so there's a
history and there's a sense from the
parties that they're looking back and
they're asking the court to look back
throughout the course of what may have
been a very long-term relationship with
ups and downs but carrying forward as a
team and now they're not a team anymore
so there's a real emotional component
there there's also the sense I think
from litigants who are involved in these
cases that their whole world in terms of
where they live what they do what they
can rely on for finances
is being turned upside down and in some
ways is being shaken by the process to
see what sorts out and
finally if it's a contested parenting
issue there's nothing that touches
people more closely than their
relationship with their children
and that's at risk and they find
themselves in a process that's sort of
foreign to them in terms of the
terminology and the forms and someone
from their point of view is reaching out
to change that relationship that they
have with their children it's it's not a
Wonder to me at all that it's a very
tense emotional kind of a process all we
can do is try to make it as Fair as we
can and and let the parties do as much
as they can Empower them to do as much
as they can to try to resolve their
cases on their own it's their children
it's their lives we really don't want to
be rearranging those things if we don't
have to and if they can do it so we
encourage that but it doesn't make the
cases much easier
before we listen to the final few
questions I want everybody to know that
we will be adjourning at 4 30 or in your
terms to billable hours
and uh
no they get us they get a salary I know
so um we'll have a few more questions
and any of you who may stay please do
and we'll hang out and ask you private
questions
you know uh this question I'm I'm I'm
altering it just a little bit to make it
maybe a little bit broader to capture
what I think are is a matter that that
I've heard issues on
um people raising questions about
um can you explain the process for uh by
which the uh the record is made uh when
when a case is being heard uh how a
party can get a copy of the of the
record
um and if there are you know if the
party is Indigent are there funds
available to to to Aid that process and
when if ever is the wreck is a record
not made
first thing I do when we get new judges
is tell them that the record you do not
want to do anything that's not on the
record the old days when we practice law
on Spirit core a lot was done in
Chambers law was done off the record
deals were made
we tell our new judges everything is
done in open court on the record our
FTR for the record equipment is kind of
antiquated some of it's some of the
machines that we have in the courts are
are older than others some are hooked
into our Network we have varying stages
of equipment and we're trying to replace
it as we have the funds to do that it's
the judge's responsibility to make sure
that the record is on when there's a
hearing going
as I said at the outset sometimes the
judge him or herself or a court security
officer someone is actually the one
that's turning the machine on we don't
have court monitors and we've had
certainly cases where everyone thought
the record was running and the case is
done and someone files as a notice of
appeal and they go to retrieve the
record and it's not there because it was
some kind of a malfunction because we
don't have court monitors sitting there
making sure the record's you know
working all the time that's not a good
thing I would love to have court
monitors like the superior report does
which would pretty much ensure that in
every case the record will be done and
operating properly anyone can order a
copy of the audio from a hearing they do
it through the clerk's office as a fee I
think it's 25 to get a copy of the CD
transcripts are ordered through and out
we Outsource those to escribers which is
an independent company that we they
download the audio to them and they have
transcriptionists that type the record
in cases where parties are Indigent and
qualify for appointed counsel like a
public defender situation the state pays
the cost of the transcripts if it's a
civil case and the parties are appealing
or just want a copy of the record they
pay a per page cost it it goes up
depending on how quickly you want the
transcript if you want it in seven days
it's so much a page if you can wait 30
days it the cost is reduced but there
should be a record available
for every case in the Circuit Court in
Superior Court as well and and hopefully
the equipment's functioning properly the
judges during the course of a hearing I
know you may have heard some testimony
during a hearing judge doesn't have a
secret lever on the bench that they can
turn off and on
um secretly turn the record on and off
the Record is either on or it's not and
you'll if when you go to visit courts
and I encourage you all of you to do
that we'll be be happy to host you on
the judge's bench you'll see a digital
display with a Time on it in Big Red
Letters and those numbers are turning
that means the records that means the
record's on the recording is on
and that the record is functioning
hopefully properly again in the Superior
Court you'll see a court monitor sitting
in front of the bench with headphones on
and they're constantly making sure all
the microphones are working and that
there's no hiccups with the record we we
don't have that we just don't have that
luxury and fortunately most of the time
the record is okay but as I said from
time to time we'll have an appeal filed
and there'll be a problem with a record
and typically in that case the case has
to be retried there's really no other
remedy so we don't want that to happen
one more question or topic
so um this question uh
why do judges call suisponty hearings
not at the request of either party can
you just sort of
tell us if that happens with any
regularity and why it might happen
it probably happens from time to time
when a case has been sitting for a
period of time and something hasn't been
scheduled for example if there were a
temporary Hearing in temporary orders
were entered and there was no order then
for a pre-trial conference or for a
final hearing whatever it might be and
the case is sat for a little while
because the court was expecting
something to be filed or something had
been filed and we were waiting for the
objection
then the court might the court clerk
might bring the case to the judge's
attention and say what's going on with
this what do we need and then we would
typically we'd look at it and typically
schedule a status conference or a
pre-trial conference if one hasn't
happened to keep the case moving
um
those are the only circumstances I can
think of outside of the emergency
category when something is filed as an
emergency and something has to happen
right away
cord is going to schedule a hearing it's
either going to be after Services
achieved on the other on the other party
or if it's a pending case it's going to
be within a period of time that the
court thinks necessary to let the
parties prepare but to get orders out as
quickly as possible after a hearing so
from time to time the clerks will bring
cases to our attention and just ask what
should we schedule here nothing's been
scheduled and we'll do that
um so I guess it is suicante but it's
really just typically a means of getting
the case back on track in the usual case
when we do a temporary hearing part of
the temporary orders will say Discovery
to be complete by this period of time
schedule a pre-trial conference after
discovery is complete or if the case has
limited issues and we can schedule a
final hearing with confidence that they
need the amount of time being scheduled
we'll just schedule a final hearing then
that issue is taken care of so it does
happen sometimes and typically it's just
the Court's way of nudging the case back
onto track
thank you
well I'm going to let you bang the gavel
because I started
um
this concludes our wonderful two-hour
presentation thank you and I hope this
isn't the last I hope we'll see you
again sometime and yeah we'll take you
up on we're going to do a road trip or
two in 26 years as a judge I never used
a gavel but I'll use it today
thank you very much thank you